hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be taking a look at all of the
known languages of magical beasts and
creatures within the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter from A to Z sadly there are
actually no magical languages that start
with a B C D or even e in fact the first
language that we'll be taking a look at
isn't even really a language at all
starting us off is the letter f for
fairies now surprising as it may be
fairies actually cannot talk at least
not in the human sense I for one would
have assumed that they spoke human
languages but of course without the
ability to speak they do not have any
notable language instead this magical
creature communicates with other fairies
through a series of loud buzzing sounds
this information can be verified in the
book Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find
Them despite its human-like appearance
the fairy cannot speak it may makes a
high-pitched buzzing noise to
communicate with its fellows next up we
have G for giant and gobbledygook now
since we're going alphabetically let's
begin with the language of the Giants
within the series the best opportunity
we have to observe a giant is of course
Hagrid's half-brother grop and it is
through both grop and the tribe of
giants who Hagrid attempts to form an
alliance with that we are given evidence
of a giant language since Hagrid is
unable to properly communicate with the
tribe and crop and yet they are able to
communicate with each other proof of a
language or at least some basic form of
communication can also be seen in the
use of the Giant's term gerg which is
the title given to the strongest Giants
and therefore leader of a tribe that
said the name and true functionality of
the Giant's language is unknown it's
also worth noting that some Giants have
been reported to speak basic English the
second language starting with G is
gobbledygo the well-recognized language
of the goblin species gobbledygook is a
widely documented language for example
it is one of 72 languages Miranda
goshawk's book of spells was translated
and published in also proving that it
can be written as well as spoken
gobbledygook chatter can be heard in
Diagon Alley amongst the Goblins
employed by Gringotts Wizarding Bank
many of the witches and wizards who have
heard it describe it as being a rough
and unmelodius tongue a string of
rattling guttural noises however despite
it being an unpleasant sounding language
it is indeed a teachable one meaning
that you do not need to be a goblin to
speak gobbledygook we know this to be
true because there are several witches
and wizards who are or were able to
speak it such as bartik senior although
bhaticrat senior is probably not the
most relatable example since he was
somewhat of a language connoisseur and
could speak over 200 languages including
murmish and troll in in addition to
gobbledygook the next few letters in the
alphabet namely h i j k and l are all
without a language to share which brings
us to M for mermish we first learned
about the murmish language in the Goblet
of Fire when Harry speaks to the mer
people who reside in the Great Lake
during his participation in the triumphs
of tournament what we discover through
Harry's interactions is that the native
language of the mer people is an
incredibly unique one due to the fact
that mermesh has been purposely adapted
for use underwater it sounds quite
different when spoken above water versus
below underwater murmish sounds like a
human language such as when Harry hears
it while in the great lake and
understands the mer people to be
speaking English but above water it is
completely unrecognizable sounding like
harsh raspy screeching similar to
gobbledygook mermish can be taught to
non-mur people as proven by the fact
that Albus Dumbledore was a fluent
speaker of the underwater language
it also has a written form once again
proven by the fact that Miranda
golshawk's book of spells was also
published in murmish for our next
language we must once again skip ahead
this time to the letter P for parcel
tongue and pixie parcel tongue is one of
the better known mystical languages
found within the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter it is spoken by magical
Serpentine creatures like the Basilisk
horn serpent or as seen in the
Philosopher's Stone a regular old snake
Apostle tongue has a unique Cadence to
it and as you may expect sounds a lot
like the hissing noises of a snake any
human that has the ability to speak
parcel tongue is known as a parcel mouth
and it's interesting to note that this
particular language is a skill that is
very much hereditary with the most
obvious exception of course being Harry
Potter which can be explained by the
fact that he was one of Voldemort's
horcruxes speaking of which just about
every known parcel mouth is a descendant
of Salazar Slytherin including the gaunt
family and Lord Voldemort himself those
particularly skilled in speaking parcel
tongue can do so without the presence of
snakes a rather fun fact about parcel
tongue is that Francis J Nolan professor
of phonetics at the University of
Cambridge created an actual language to
represent parcel tongue in the films
another magical creature with its own
unique form of communication is the
pixie although there isn't much
documented on an official language it's
not impossible that one exists Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them explains
that Pixies produce a high-pitched
jabbering intelligible only two other
Pixies in my opinion this leaves the
door open for that jabbering to be a
form of structured communication moving
right along past Q we come to R for
runes runes is a particularly unique
language in that this is only known in
its written form there is no verbal
counterpart it consists entirely of
symbols referred to as the runic
language which has its own alphabet the
language is taught as an advanced course
for sixth years at Hogwarts the study of
ancient runes you may also remember
seeing it in the series series inscribed
within Dumbledore's pensive and in the
children's book the tales of beetle The
Bard last but not least we skipped past
as to T for troll according to the book
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
trolls generally Converse in grunts that
appear to constitute a crude language
though some have been known to
understand and even speak a few simple
human words we don't have much else to
go on in terms of the trolls language
considering the only troll we meet in
the Philosopher's Stone is without any
fellow comrades now if you're anything
like me this list of languages may have
you feeling a little put out surely
there are more than that well for you
and let's be honest very much for myself
I've also compiled a secondary list of
magical creatures and beings who have
the ability to speak human languages
starting with the acromantulas these are
the giant spiders found in the Forbidden
Forest that brought Ron's nightmares to
life they are incredibly intelligent and
have the ability
combine those two and you have enormous
talking spiders yikes centaurs I mean
this seems pretty obvious considering
this magical being's upper body is that
of a human if I'm being honest I'm more
surprised by the fact that they don't
have their own language or do they
dwarves again nothing groundbreaking
here but worth noting in the Chamber of
Secrets we see dwarves delivering
Valentine's messages around Hogwarts at
the request of Professor gilderoy
Lockhart a little odd but at the very
least it shows they speak English
similar to centaurs I'm somewhat
surprised that they don't have a
language of their own gnomes ah gnomes
odd little buggers aren't they in the
Wizarding World gnomes are garden pests
that are common in North America and
Northern Europe the Weasley family seems
to have somewhat of a known problem at
the burrow as they can be heard swearing
in the garden in English house elves I
suppose due to the relationship between
ourselves and wizard kind it should come
as no surprise they speak human
languages and not one of their own that
said the grammatical errors with which
they speak does suggest that perhaps
they do or did have a language of their
own perhaps it has been lost throughout
the centuries of indentured servitude or
maybe it never existed at all the Javi
this magical creature is not seen in the
Harry Potter series at all but we know
from Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find
Them that it is essentially a large
ferret that can talk apparently it also
has the rare ability to teach itself
human languages
leprechauns this will shock no one
leprechauns can speak human languages no
no please hold your applause I know my
greatest Theory yet manticores similar
to centaurs and they are part human part
Beast manticores are an incredibly
dangerous magical creature that has the
head of a human the body of a lion and
the tale of a scorpion plus it can speak
the Sphinx this magical creature is
capable of human speech but as we see in
the Gob to fire will only talk in
Puzzles or riddles velas the last
magical being on our list today is the
Villa these are beautiful female
humanoid magical creatures with white
gold hair and Moon bright skin Avila's
appearance will change when they are
angry but all that to say is that they
can definitely speak human languages
after all Fleur de la core was part
Villa and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
did I miss any languages or magical
creatures capable of human speech please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign